think my number one advice today would
be you have to try your Duke and I'm not
trying to sell the software here I
really do believe that if I have had the
software we have today at the beginning
of my journey I would have saved a lot
of money and time and so on building up
all our I.T infrastructure
um I I lost so much money because I
didn't like to send follow-up to the to
the to my clients it was administrative
and I'm very bad at doing a
administrative tasks but not reinvoicing
expenses or anything like that if I
would have had or do at the time I think
I would have saved a lot of money and a
lot of time so I really recommend people
to have a look at it because it's a game
changer there you go well it's about
odoo but it's about having tools that
can help you with these things save
yourself a lot of time so you know
marketing automation Erp it's never too
early to get good Tools in place